no you can look it up you can look it up
where where do they get the bacteria
culture for yako I think it's actually
from human poop no they ferment milk
yeah
it's our base okay look it up where does
where does Yakov bacteria come from
[Music]
all right
um I don't know if we should be alarmed
by this I think
um I'm not alarmed at all okay dude we
can't keep eating my cookies bro sorry
sorry guys
so it
um it has now been found that
STDs are an all-time high oh shoot
specifically syphilis is spreading at a
rate and having more cases wow the it's
never been this High since 1950 so we're
in a [__] full Bull Run you don't
really hear about syphilis that much do
you hear the popular ones you hear
chlamydia you hear gonorrhea but you
forget you forget about syphilis I think
it's because it's easier to tell
somebody like if it's chlamydia that's
just more regular so people are just not
saying because you know syphilis is like
the Beethoven STD that's just old school
didn't Al Capone have syphilis I don't
know but you know you get uh you get
insane off of that's what they said
about Al Capone yeah but if you become a
musical genius too in a in a big time
criminal like well the the tough part is
they're saying that most of the cases
that get found out are found out
coincidentally when you're in there for
something else really so it's not that
more people are getting tested and
they're going like hey I got symptoms so
check me out it's more like they're
going in for routine um checkups and
they're finding syphilis or even worse
like a lot of these cases are being
passed down to babies that are born oh
[__] [__] so syphilis when you get
syphilis what are the symptoms that come
about when you get syphilis is this
considered a pandemic I don't think it's
considered a pandemic it's just a really
high rate oh my God that's a lot of
people have a lot of sex and that one's
not curable right it's not it's it's
curable yeah it's just it's undetectable
it's just dangerous let's go get tested
yeah
uh it's it's a lot dude it's like 100
was it the last year was
176 713.
holy moly dude [__] so there's more out
there
there's more out there than that because
not everyone's getting tested so people
don't really know there's five
in 2021 there was 220 uh babies that
died at Birth because because of
syphilis yeah does that make your pee
burn is that that one no it's not on
that's chlamydia why are you trying to
act all no I swear to God
unfamiliar
I have syphilis you guys hey you're
really going for the Oscar bro no I'm
really curious he's asking for a friend
I'm really curious
yeah so it's like oh so it's transmitted
by sex what is it really what's sex
honestly let me look it up because even
I don't know because it is kind of a
sleeper even I don't believe it or not
aren't the top ones like gonorrhea
chlamydia syphilis I don't know what
they all are though really HPV the the
big three gonorrhea syphilis and uh
chlamydia chlamydia yeah so here's the
um the uh symptoms fever swollen lymph
nodes sore throat patchy hair loss
headaches weight loss muscle aches
fatigue and what is that sounds like
food like symptoms syphilis okay yeah
dude that sounds like a million things
that WebMD has said I have but all like
a lack of sleep but also you go cuckoo
too right yeah yeah because it says the
final stage can result in damage to the
brain nerves eyes and heart oh my God I
need all of those
a little penicillin that's it just
antibiot bacterials come on come on
that's all you need come on yeah hey I'm
telling people man y'all need to eat you
need to drink yakult you just got to
take the right antibiotics
that's it you see you say antibiotics I
say probiotics hey you know I I was
looking up this like this uh video this
is totally separate from syphilis but
this is more about yakult and I was
looking it up because growing up I would
be like yeah cult this is like a sugary
drink but there really is really good
probiotics yes there is lactobacilliasis
I'm telling you dude it's the best [__]
in the world I'm gonna derives from
Human [__] okay man that bacteria that's
E coli man no no it's derived they take
it from a bacteria strain that's in your
poop E coli and probiotics
you can look it up you can look it up
where where do they get the bacteria
culture for yako I think it's actually
from human poop no they ferment milk
yeah I think it's got to be milk because
it's lactose the name is lactose that's
a sugar base okay look it up where does
where does yacobacteria come from if
you're wrong can you have to eat hot
sauce yeah and this won't help our
sponsorship with yakult instantly
backtracking yeah check it out watch you
can't make claims like that
strain of bacteria called lactobacillus
ramnosis see that's the lactose the bad
fatty acid okay okay you're half right
it was discovered in 83 when it was
isolated from the feces of a healthy
American see no it doesn't come from
there it exists in our gut and then they
identified it in the poop doesn't mean
that they extract it from the poop and
put it into them what they did they said
they they reproduced that same bacteria
from the original sample so it's from
some other guy's [__] ew we're just
drinking [__] bro but at least she's an
American hell yeah brother a healthy one
the one spot
from [__] yeah that's from chocolate
it's the right color hold on no I'm
saying all I'm saying is it was
discovered from Human [__] okay okay
well I thought you said someone's
[__] into my yakult how would we not
take offense to that can you know I
thought there was a Japanese man in the
assembly line going yeah but then it did
not taste good
like they're just cloning that same
bacteria and that came from the [__] oh
geez can stop cursing I I see the
positive effects of [__] probiotics
right like there's this guy that does
microscope videos on YouTube it's so
sick like it's just she's like this is
what it looks like when you get [__]
bacteria right he showed uh yakult and
he's like there's so much probiotics in
there I was like I think I watched the
same guy I was like how much is really
in this bottle yeah because it looks
like a nothing looks like sugary drink
and he goes I had to zoom in more than I
usually do because there was so much
that's the video I saw is it more in
there
check oh Greek yogurt is really good for
you though yeah they got tons of people
and they got protein it says it's made
from uh some Greek guys come oh
I believe that
Greek yogurt I'm gonna give you a little
bit of info that's gonna sell and
support what you said earlier so it says
a probiotic may act indirectly
through treating and preventing
bacterial vaginosis which means I ain't
got no vaginosis
that's not me but
[__] with the yako it could it could
secrete endogenous and exogenous
substances that block HIV and STI
transmission wow so it actually
strengthens drugs
okay so there's this new study where
probiotics there's they're linking how
eczema could be caused by like dysfungus
and all this stuff but it's also because
we use all these like chemicals in our
shampoos that actually wipe out all the
bacteria yeah and then and then and then
like because of that it the fungus grows
without anything combating it so now
there's like probiotic soaps and
shampoos that you could put in your hair
and your body and your skin and it makes
your skin live and healthy again no I
heard your teeth also has good bacteria
too so you're not you're not supposed to
get rid of it no certain toothpaste
certain toothpaste mouthwash it kills
the good bacteria too and what I just
learned is you're actually not supposed
to brush your teeth for two minutes it's
only supposed to be for like as long as
like a happy birthday song my friend
says because he's which kind though at a
black party yeah no it's but it's not
supposed to be as long as we think I'll
break it down because that's the best
kind of happy birthday but once I
started doing that I I was like you know
what they're probably right so I don't
brush my teeth as long as I used to
because I feel like the more you do that
it breaks your enamel down bro I brush
my teeth for like three four minutes dog
you've probably got nice teeth let me
see no dude I'm self-conscious now
please don't look do you drink coffee
not anymore
I drink energy drinks brother oh good
zoom in on his teeth when he said that
we got a good shot of it have you guys
used those pills those plaque pills that
you chew and it stains all the area that
you do have plaque and then where do you
get that at get on Amazon yeah that's it
and then um
get the tools the the carving tools and
just chisel away at those [__]
that's what they get
kids that way they can tell they're
going to brush their teeth yeah where to
brush their teeth yeah
I'll go first no yeah I'm just kidding
the amount of unprotected sex I've had
though I'm so surprised I got lucky
because like there's so many diseases
out there and I'm just like hey you know
why you didn't get it because yakult
yeah the the power of yaakov's strong
dude I pour that [__] all over my body I
have a yakult bath and your partners
don't get at least four thousand bottles
it's expensive is it true that if you
shower before before and after sex you
reduce your chance of like Contracting
an STD if you shower before and after
right now like this rinse and then you
do it and then you rinse again to make
sure there's nothing I would assume so
maybe I wouldn't know would you sh do
you shower before and after you have sex
I always do it after is that insulting
for the lady no
they they like clean men after after
hey man
you're just like
oh that was so disgusting you wouldn't
be insulted of a dude just like be lined
into the shower right after it was just
like scrubbing furiously while staring
at you I mean in that tone Maybe
it's kind of strange though because I
feel like I've honestly never I've heard
guys say they had chlamydia yeah cool
guys and uh and a couple other things
but I've never heard one person be like
oh yeah syphilis yeah I'm never a dad
but now we have a syphilis outbreak yeah
and that's supposed to be the highest
thing out of everything right and when I
think of syphilis I think like old like
Medieval Europe or like something old
you know like I don't think of modern I
think my boys just got to get their
numbers up as it's going on I'm not
seeing results yeah you guys aren't
getting enough syphilis man
What's a Brother Gotta Do to get some
syphilis around here
can I get some symbolism yeah
what's up baby
[Music]